Kona training diary it's Thursday eight
days out Jason and I are gonna hit a
little one-hour tape around that's right
so it's been a good day we just checked
our bikes into Bike Works have them all
rigged up for the race break that out to
Zoo
check out the new 2010 soup bags red and
black never stop colors what about these
shoes the 2010 energy to point out
that's right super nice and we stopped
by the post office today and got some
more goodies care package got uh these
new Swiss eye shades care of uh mark
cats it Sportiva import all right look
at that gold shades I feel like these
are my Usain Bolt shades for the run
what do you think the first person that
post on your blog or our blog gets a
free never stop fitted hat so sporty
Vanport are a check these shades out
pretty sweet little tweak out here oh
and he sent some hats to some cool Swiss
Alps it's just something hats some stuff
from the three live some good stuff and
then we got a sweet care package from
Lloyd and Theresa try lab check these
out cool try lab tees I can't wait to
support that more III live more t-shirts
some tubes to try lab bottles that's a
new trial app logo it's pretty sweet
we got some that boy that's a nice to
take a shoot away so pretty psyched
check right Theresa the whole trial AB
through Los Angeles California
triathlon lab calm thanks for getting
our back out here in Kona Hawaii for all
your multi-sport needs love you miss you
will see you guys in a couple weeks